Traduttore: Maurizio Berti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera,
io sono colui che vi
separa dalla pausa caffè.
(Risate)
Noi stiamo vivendo un momento storico
molto interessante.
Alcuni ancora sono bizzarramente convinti
che si tratti di una crisi economica.
Quelli più lungimiranti hanno capito
che non è in realtà una crisi economica,
ma è un cambiamento di paradigmi.
Stanno proprio cambiando
le regole del gioco.
Voi immaginate per un attimo
di avere vissuto durante
la Rivoluzione Industriale.
Facevate i contadini,
e a un certo punto è arrivata
una tecnologia, da qualche parte,
che ha permesso di costruire
una cosa che si chiamava "fabbriche".
Questa tecnologia ha avuto un impatto
sia sul cambiamento dell'economia
ma anche sulla società,
e molti contadini si sono spostati
dalle campagne alla città.
È stato un cambiamento di regole,
un cambiamento di modelli,
e noi stiamo vivendo
un periodo molto simile.
Sempre, alla base di tutto,
c'è la disponibilità di nuove tecnologie
che ci permettono di fare cose
che prima non potevamo fare.
Queste sono driver,
spingono i cambiamenti.
Abbiamo difficoltà a capire o a immaginare
quale può essere il futuro:
non siamo degli indovini.
Però quello che possiamo fare
è pensare di immaginare un futuro
partendo da alcuni segnali
che dal futuro ci arrivano,
e che in realtà, poi, sono già presenti.
Durante la mia presentazione,
che ho fatto tutta in lettere
perché sono un giornalista,
e quindi mi esprimo meglio così
che non con le immagini,
arriveremo a raccontarvi anche
che già qualcuno sta implementando
questo tipo di modelli.
Questi segnali che arrivano dal futuro
ci dicono alcune cose molto interessanti.
Partiamo con queste
che ho chiamato keywords:
abbiamo appunto
il cambiamento dei paradigmi
- che è la giusta interpretazione
invece della crisi economica.
Ma abbiamo due parole molto importanti:
decentralizzazione
e crescita esponenziale.
Decentralizzazione
è una parola chiave
perché, poi vedremo,
è quella che ci permette
di capire uno dei pilastri
di questo cambiamento paradigmatico.
La crescita esponenziale
è un altro elemento importante.
Noi dobbiamo tenere in considerazione
che la disponibilità di tecnologie,
e l'evoluzione delle stesse,
non evolve con un processo lineare,
ma evolve con una rapidità esponenziale.
La velocità con la quale questo tipo
di tecnologie diventa disponibile
Ogni tanto, quando vado
a fare qualche lezione,
in qualche liceo o in qualche Università,
faccio quest'esempio:
immaginate che oggi sia il 2008,
quindi non molti anni fa,
e io dicessi una frase del tipo:
ho scaricato un app
sul mio smartphone Android.
Probabilmente
mi prendereste per visionario
perché né smartphone, né Android,
né app, erano presenti all'epoca.
Oggi è una cosa comune.
Per cui immaginate solo questo:
in soli pochi anni quanto è cambiata
la nostra percezione.
Altri segnali che ci arrivano dal futuro
sono il superamento della dicotomia
tra profit e no-profit.
Noi siamo abituati a pensare
alle organizzazioni che fanno profitto,
come organizzazioni cattive,
o comunque non buone
in tutto ciò che fanno;
e invece siamo abituati a pensare
che per fare cose buone
dobbiamo applicare
il concetto del no-profit.
In realtà questo è un processo
che sta per essere superato.
Esiste anche una nuova forma di impresa
che si chiama benefit corporation.
L'Italia è il secondo paese al mondo
ad avere una normativa apposita,
che è stata approvata lo scorso dicembre.
Le benefit corporation,
che possono essere aziende di ogni tipo
e di ogni settore, di ogni dimensione,
hanno nel loro dna, nel loro processo,
sia la capacità di generare profitti,
valore economico, creare posti di lavoro,
sia quella di avere un impatto sociale
e ambientale positivo.
Il neo-nomadismo o nomadismo digitale
è un altro fenomeno, un altro segnale
che ci arriva dal futuro
e che ci dice che sempre più persone,
in questo pianeta,
hanno capito che ci si può
liberare dalla connessione
tra il lavoro che si fa
e il luogo dove si vive.
Ovvero a riguardo del lavoro
– questo vale per alcuni mestieri,
non per tutti ancora naturalmente –
c'è una buona fetta di popolazione
che ha capito che il suo lavoro
non deve necessariamente essere
legato a un territorio.
Per cui si muove,
e va in giro per il mondo,
vive un po' qua e un po' là.
Questi sono i cosiddetti nomadi digitali,
in quanto digitale è l'infrastruttura
che gli consente questo.
Altra parola chiave: blockchain,
questa è un'altra parola chiave
molto interessante, molto importante,
quasi come la parola Internet,
perché blockchain è una tecnologia,
uno strato, quasi
una filosofia tecnologica,
che consente di implementare
il concetto di decentralizzazione
– poi vi spiego come.
Poi ho citato altri due punti che sono:
la presenza delle città-stato,
città che sempre di più,
per importanza,
sostituiranno il valore
dei Governi nazionali.
La cultura imprenditoriale
di nuova generazione,
quella delle startup,
è un altro elemento importante
perché è una cultura che è nuova
rispetto al modo in cui
si faceva impresa precedentemente,
ed è soprattutto globale.
Tutto ciò si scontra
con un sistema
che è attualmente inefficiente:
le attuali democrazie
di tipo rappresentativo,
quelle maggiormente diffuse al mondo oggi,
stanno dimostrando
di non essere più sistemi efficaci.
Perché concentrano il potere,
perché consentono
allo strato di rappresentatività
di prendere decisioni
non sempre condivise,
perché rischiano di essere foriere
di corruzione, di sprechi
e del mantenimento
delle rendite di posizione.
Gli stati-nazioni sono sempre più deboli
nella loro importanza,
nell'equilibrio socio-economico
che si sta creando.
Altri sistemi che oggi funzionano
con modelli centralizzati
sono ad esempio
la distribuzione di energia elettrica.
L'energia elettrica
viene distribuita tramite centrali,
che da qualche parte
producono energia
che poi nelle nostre case,
uffici, fabbriche, scuole,
arriva con delle reti di trasporto.
Sistema assolutamente inefficiente,
dispersivo, altamente costoso.
Oggi le grandi aziende che fanno energia
e che stanno portando energia elettrica
in quelle parti del mondo
dove ancora non è arrivata,
non lo fanno così com'è da noi,
ma lo fanno con tecnologie
che consentono di produrre energia
nello stesso posto dove viene consumata:
sistema decentralizzato.
L'altro esempio è quello dei bitcoin.
I bitcoin sono molto importanti
perché sono la dimostrazione pratica
del concetto di blockchain
di cui vi dicevo prima.
I bitcoin, qualcuno di voi
ne ha sentito parlare sicuramente,
sono la prima cripto-moneta,
e sono innovativi
non solo perchè sono digitali
o perché sono sovranazionali,
ma sono innovativi perché non c'è
la banca centrale dei bitcoin.
Quindi noi abbiamo una valuta,
che viene trasmessa su Internet,
quindi mantiene la proprietà,
e che non è gestita
da un sistema centrale.
Questi modelli, la democrazia diretta,
cioè l'eliminazione
dello strato intermedio
tra i cittadini e l'entità
che poi gestisce
amministrativamente la cosa pubblica,
è già una realtà per esempio
nei cantoni svizzeri.
L'holacrazia,
che è il sistema non solo decentralizzato,
ma anche non gerarchico,
è già una realtà applicata
da alcune organizzazioni e imprese.
Per esempio, usano un sistema olocratico
imprese come Medium
che è questo nuovo sistema,
anche abbastanza noto e diffuso,
che molti usano per pubblicare
contenuti su internet.
Lo è la società che si chiama Automatik,
che è quella che fa Wordpress,
che molti usano per fare siti web.
La panarchia invece
è una possibile evoluzione
sulla quale si sta ragionando
e che è molto legata
al concetto di nomadismo digitale,
ed è quella che dice:
se noi scolleghiamo
il lavoro dal territorio,
possiamo anche scollegare
i sistemi legislativi,
e metterli in competizione tra loro.
E sta già succedendo:
Bitnation è un'organizzazione
che sta definendo
modelli organizzativi degli Stati
secondo il concetto della Blockchain
- tutte queste cose sono
liberamente consultabili su Internet -
Ethereum è una start-up
che sta sviluppando un sistema
per la gestione, basata sulla blockchain,
dei contratti, degli Smart Contract.
Quindi anche chi fa l'avvocato,
quindi un mestiere che noi siamo abituati
a considerare solido e consolidato,
sarà oggetto di questo forte mutamento.
Teleport e Nomadlist sono due siti
che aiutano coloro i quali
vogliono fare il nomade
a scegliere il posto migliore
dove andare a vivere
sulla base delle
caratteristiche economiche,
sociali, di preferenze,
climatiche o quant'altro.
Il governo dell'Estonia,
un paese dell'Unione Europea
che usa l'euro
– quindi non stiamo parlando
di un altro pianeta –
ha già da qualche mese
reso disponibile la residenza elettronica.
Badate bene: sto parlando
di residenza, non di cittadinanza,
per cui le tasse
le continuate a pagare qui.
Chiunque di noi può diventare
un residente virtuale dell'Estonia,
senza esserci mai stato fisicamente.
Io scommetto che molti di voi
non sanno neanche qual è
la capitale dell'Estonia.
Però potete diventare estoni
dal punto di vista della residenza.
Perché è importante avere
questo tipo di residenza elettronica?
Perché se tu sei un nomade digitale,
e ti muovi spesso,
quindi non hai
una residenza fisica stabile,
però quando devi aprire un conto in banca,
devi aprire una società
o devi firmare un contratto,
ti serve avere questa residenza;
e il Governo estone
ti dà questa possibilità
indipendentemente da tu chi sia,
puoi andare sul sito,
paghi 50 euro una volta,
loro ti mandano una smart card
e con quella fai tutto.
Altri esempi interessanti sono:
Medium, Automatik e Zappos
li abbiamo già citati,
però per esempio Suigeneris
è un'organizzazione,
un gruppo di imprenditori canadesi
che sta cercando di sviluppare un modello
- loro lo chiamano appunto
"startup cities" -
dove l'organizzazione di questi territori
è fatta in un modo in cui l'economia
deriva dal sostenere
lo sviluppo di imprese innovative
che, nell'ambito dei numeri possibili,
diventano potenzialmente delle imprese
che fanno molti soldi,
per cui lasciano poi sul territorio
dei ritorni economici.
I cittadini di queste "startup cities"
non pagano le tasse ma lavorano,
cioè danno un contributo volontario
affinché il sistema funzioni.
Questi signori stanno lavorando
per stringere accordi
con alcuni paesi europei
affinché venga dato loro
un pezzetto del territorio
per poter implementare
questo tipo di cose.
Cito inoltre gli ecosistemi delle start up
che si stanno sviluppando
in tutto il mondo,
perché sono un esempio molto interessante
per capire come, se voi andate sul web
e fate una qualsiasi ricerca
che metta a confronto questi sistemi,
scoprirete che il confronto viene fatto
sulla base dei sistemi urbani.
Quindi non c'è confronto
tra gli ecosistemi delle start up
in Italia, in Francia, ecc.,
ma c'è soprattutto quello tra Londra,
Parigi, Berlino, Stoccolma, Lisbona,
Milano, Silicon Valley...
Quindi anche in questo caso
stiamo vedendo come ci arriva
un segnale di questo tipo:
i sistemi organizzativi urbani
stanno acquisendo sempre più potere,
rispetto ai sistemi di organizzazione
che noi conosciamo
con il nome di stato nazione.
Queste sono informazioni
che sono in continua evoluzione,
sono un modo per cercare di comprendere
come è possibile che sarà il futuro,
ed è un modo che chiunque di noi
che voglia fare l'imprenditore,
il viaggiatore, l'agricoltore
l'avvocato, o il giornalista,
deve sapere, deve quantomeno
tenere presente.
Perché accade, sta accadendo,
stanno già arrivando queste cose.
Non possiamo non esserne
almeno consapevoli.
Quindi questo è un po'
il messaggio che vi voglio dare:
tenete d'occhio questo tipo di evoluzione.
Quando io ho iniziato a fare
la carriera del giornalista
l'Internet stava muovendo i primi passi,
e quindi i giornalisti
che iniziavano il mestiere,
per accrescere più rapidamente
la loro reputazione,
cercavano di andare a lavorare
per giornali molto ben conosciuti,
quindi associare la propria firma
al nome del giornale noto.
Oggi accade esattamente il contrario:
coloro che si lanciano
nella professione giornalistica,
costruiscono prima la loro reputazione
usando Internet,
quindi associando il livello
di reputazione al proprio nome.
E poi sono i grandi giornali
che vanno a caccia
di questi giornalisti sul web.
Quindi stanno proprio cambiando
tutti i sistemi e tutte le regole,
e il mio messaggio è:
non distraetevi,
perché sennò sarete colpiti
da questa ondata
che sta arrivando prepotentemente.
Grazie a tutti e buon caffè.
(Applausi)